things going and all sorts of stuff yeah
something better it is so we have seven
layers of security from the boundary
fence line all the way through to the IT
in the rack and what you've just
experienced there is the access from
what we turn the general area operations
on the well we turn the fluffy side of
the building to the secure side of the
building which is where the data halls
and all the IT infrastructure resides so
going through what we call this - block
circle or contraption you have to go
into the lock itself and put your finger
onto the finger vein reader and the
finger vein reader rather than just a
traditional fingerprint reader actually
searches for signs of life so as to make
sure that you have an edge of finger cut
off and someone's brought you through so
it's quite extreme it does seem a bit
over the top but it does give the
customers the assurance that it's very
difficult to get into the facility and
do anything untoward with their IT we
are going to go into the JISC shared
data so again we got further security
access into here nice we'll come on
you're going to follow me through
so what you see here are various pods
with IT racks within them and within
their axes or the IT infrastructure for
each of the customers so we have a
number of the anchor customers from the
Janik consortium in here such as UCL
King's College the Francis Crick
Institute we also have Imperial College
I'll take you through some of the pots
now
what's called high performance computing
so each of these racks are full with HPC
platforms and on the other side is the
storage is also platform so this is all
utilize for medical research
and it's consortium of UCL the Francis
Crick and the Sanger Institute so
they've come together as a single entity
if you like through funding to provide
this service and then take called
medical research within the building
storage is 10 petabytes of data and the
the IT load that is supported by some
190 kilowatts of power this is the
single largest installation of its type
outside CERN so give you some sort of
context of the scale of it so they're
very proud of it
all sort of a similar sides a berries
depending upon the requirement but what
we do have in this room is predominately
high performance computing doing
research so you've got to Kings College
over there doing something similar but
that's that's a row Knight structure the
other thing is they're saying I'm
instituting the far corner doing
something similar as well and then we
have smaller customers more traditional
education organizations that have
traditional business applications such
as the London School of Economics who
are doing their own you know teaching
learning applications and then their own
IT functions for HR and Finance and
that's the thing so it's all that it's
across the board really traditional
traditional IT edibility along with the
research side so this is the King's
College installation similar format to
what we've seen but this is a slightly
less powered and they do a number of
they do a number of phenomena medical
research on their own systems and
they've migrated a lot of their
infrastructure from their own campus in
central London and the Strand and one of
the key benefits they've seen is that
they're not being challenged by the
struggles of having this level of IT
infrastructure in central London whereby
there was an out there was a big large
power outage recently on King's way in
London which meant that their data
center went down but by having the data
center housed at a location outside
central London allowed them to care keep
these platforms running and also writing
infrastructure for running as well
we have Sanger Institute and
College in this pod here again they're
doing medical research this is the med
bed bio project so the smaller scale to
the Sanger and UCL and Tates Creek
installation but again this is very
high-powered in structure so the room
itself is 500 square meters then it's
supported by 750 kilowatts of mighty
load which is the the kilowatts to
support the room from powering the IT
and then you see those boxes on the wall
there those are the computer room air
conditioning unit they're attached to a
pipe work system with cold water that
then grates cold air that pushes the
cold air underneath the floor and then
through those floor grills and then that
cold air is then circulated through the
ITM structure and out through the rear
and then circulate through the crack
units again you're always maintaining a
level of temperature within the pod to
ensure that the i.t operates correctly
and 24/7 365 the electricity that
supports the I see you've got in effect
this is a large wall socket so it that
has a lot of power cables that come out
the bottom of it but then feed through
underneath the floor and then get
attached into these
which the IT hardware then plug into and
you will notice that this one's blue we
call it a PDU power distribution unit
and then the one over here one in the
corner over there is red and what that
means is that each cabinet each IT rack
has a power feed from the blue units and
the red units to a socket under the
floor for each providing what we call an
A plus B supply so should there be it
should there be any outages on that side
it means that the red side will support
the entire IT load for that rat for that
IT infrastructure there's a very large
primary substation at the rear of the
building which we paid for which costs a
lot of money and that is supported by
the power ring that runs around the
whole of the Slough Trading Estate and
connects into the slough Eaton power
power station and also the National Grid
as well and there are two connections
from that power ring that come in to the
primary substation at the rear of the
building and each of those two supports
to faulty megawatts of electricity the
idea being is that what should one fail
then the other one can pick up the
entire IT and falling load of the
facility and then alongside that we have
a generation set of generators which is
which are called continuously rated
generators and they are the engines that
go in ships and they can run the
building indefinitely as long as we put
fuel in them to again provide all the IT
power all the IT technology as well as
palling all dome structure as well so
the building can run in isolation
indefinitely as long as we talk about
the the engines if you like but using
these all yeah lots and lots of red
diesel
so this room is now pretty much at
capacity and we have been building a
additional piece of capacity on the
other side of that wall which provides
another 2,500 kilowatts of power this is
750 kilowatts of power and we're already
moving new customers into that space
so both UCL and Brunel are going in
there and then Queen Mary will be going
in there in the next month or so but
we're very much at the beginning of this
the datacenter developments so the
building itself and supports 16,000
kilowatts and we've only built out an
operational on 2.25 Torre 2,200
kilowatts with the further two thousand
five hundred kilowatts has gone live so
we've got the ground floor there's a
floor above us so there's lots of
capacity a lot of them are doing
standard enterprise applications for
their email for their HRA finance
systems and for the Learning Solutions
that they provide for their students but
the high powered solutions the high
performers Confucian computing is
research and that will be across various
different avenues of research
predominantly in the email lab systems
as we just see here that is medical
research and King's College focus
heavily on medical research as well
so they've reduced quite interesting
things you talked about later on we're
using these platforms to support it but
it's the high part of music allows them
to do research quicker than a standard
server as simple to get ready if they
all want to use this powerful grid
you've created how do you prioritize how
is it decided who gets to use the power
and when that is a very very more than
one network connection and there's it
pretty balanced and the controls at Lou
it it's really very comfortable and then
with this unit I can walk around my in
this room and I'm suddenly in a virtual
environment it's an optical tracking
system so they're basically